d'abord vous avez raison de dire
quelques personnes ont été tuées parce
que on a commencé à 200 puis 500 puis
probablement demain ça aurait été 2000
euh ça c'est le premier point moi j'ai
vu les images c'est plutôt un parking à
côté de l'hôpital qui a été touché euh
les informations qu'on a qui quand même
aujourd'hui se croise toutes c'est
plutôt un missile qui a été soit détruit
soit qui a raté et qui est retombé et en
retombant il a créé des dégâts voilà
mais ce missile il vit de Gaza il venait
pas d'Israël ça aujourd'hui on a
l'information on a l'ination quasiment
ouais le problème c'est que le mal est
fait le mal est fait sur avec deux
objectifs le président Biden arrivit en
Israël à ce moment-là et devait se
réunir à amaman avec Égypte Palestine
Jordanie Israël et lui et c'était
l'ouverture d'une voix politique voie
politique qui n'existe plus depuis des
années et donc c'était la bonne chose à
faire malheureusement elle a été annulée
sous le choc de cette attaque et surtout
des fausses informations qui ont été
données au départ deuxième impact ces
fausses informations écouté dans la rue
arabe sont prises pour argent comptant
et donc la rue arabe se réveille et la
rue arabe ça veut dire les gouvernements
des pays arabes qui eux souhaitaent
traiter avec Israël je rapporte les
accords drabam et puis les négociations
en cours avec l'Arabie Saoudite ben sont
tenu par la rue d'une certaine façon et
ne peuvent pas le faire donc le mal est
fait il n'y a pas eu la Réunion et il y
a une levée en masse au profit de la
cause palestinienne et moi je rappelle
toujours il faut bien qu'on sépare le
Hamas de la cause palestinienne le Hamas
sont des terroristes qui ne veulent pas
négocier qui veulent la destruction
d'Israël la Palestine a le droit à un
état mais juste on va en parler mais
juste qu'on comprenne bien est-ce que
c'était volontaire avec cette frappe ou
est-ce que c'est un accident non je
pense que c'était pas volontaire je
pense que c'était un accident et que ça
a été exploité et donc vous considérez
que c'est un tournant dans la guerre
c'était un peu les mots de Denis Bechard
un ex- diplomate en jordanier qui disait
que dans tous les cas ça portait un coup
décisif à l'image de l'État d'Israël oui
c'était c'est absolument terrible parce
que depuis le début Israël qui est sous
un choc absolu depuis le 7 octobre est
réuni pour faire quelque chose je dis
bien faire quelque chose alors ça me
rappelle une une expression quand
j'étais au nation Unis en youoslavie
quand le chef disait à New York
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire faites
quelque chose sans dire ce qu'il fallait
faire donc c'est c'est c'est terrible
d'en arriver là faut faire quelque chose
parce que le choc est trop important et
aujourd'hui les Américains et les
Européens aussi retiennent un peu la
main d'Israël en disant attention aux
populations civile ne faites pas
n'importe quoi d'où les retards qui ont
eu progressif avec un ultimatum de 24
heur puis de 48 he puis de 72h et
l'attaque qui n'a toujours pas eu lieu
et quelle forme prendra l'attaque ça
risque d'être compliqu justement vous
faites bien de de de le dire de le
préciser parce que quelles peuvent être
les les conséquences de cette de ce de
ce drame à l'hôpital de de Gaza sur les
opérations terrestres
israéliennes je pense que ça va être ça
va
insister inciter pardon ça va inciter
les Israéliens à être encore plus
prudents parce qu'il voit bien l'effet
déjà produit mais imaginez aujourd'hui
une attaque terrestre euh des chat qui
tire une famille qui est restée dans un
bloc ce qui est possible hein on va
montrer les cadavres on va les
multiplier par 10 ou 20 et là l'effet va
être absolument catastrophique mais
juste plus prudent ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il peut ne pas y avoir
d'opération terreste ça veut dire
qu'elle sera de moindre envergure ou ça
veut dire qu'elle sera reportée je pense
qu'elle sera de moindreenvergure on a vu
400000 hommes rassembler l'invasion de
Gaza je pense que ça va être plus des
incursions peut-être fortes et brutales
et puis deuxième aspect qu' fa il y en
aura une pour vous ça c'est inéluctable
ben si vous voulez on peut pas dire on
va
euh éradiquer le Hamas ce qui à mon avis
est un faux objectif le véritable
objectif c'est la destruction de
l'infrastructure du Hamas alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure il y a déjà eu
des excursions en 2014 mais ça fait 10
ans et depuis 10 ans le Hamas a
construit destas de tunnels des tas de
choses donc il faut détruire ça oui et
comment le faire là je laisserai la main
au israéliens qui sont en position pour
le faire donc ce que vous nous dites
c'est que selon vous l'État israélien
n'est pas prêt à s'embourber dans dans
Gaza je crois que plus le temps passe
plus il se rend compte après le choc qui
en 48 he fait que on y va on y va
s'aperçoit que c'est compliqué en plus
si vous voulez c'est quand même au grand
jour l'échec total de la politique de
netanahou et donc tous les discours de
netan trèsvat en guerre au début perd un
peu de crédibilité au au fur et à mesure
il est fragilisé aujourd'hui Benyamin
netaniahou par ce qui s'est passé euh
ben il est à mon avis mort politiquement
mort c'est quand même lui qui a favorisé
le Hamas cornerisé laass Jordanie qui
n'a pas écouté les information
égyptienne qui lui disait attention il
va se passer quelque chose qui
favorisait la colonisation qui est
critiquée par tout le monde en 6jordanie
donc c'est un échec absolu de sa
politique qui débouche sur quoi sur
aujourd'hui l'État vengeur alors que ça
devrait être l'état protecteur et donc
c'est une catastrophe donc je pense que
derrière le choc et moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
appelé en en Israël bien sûr il y a un
choc complet ce qu'a fait le Hamas est
totalement
inqualifiable mais au bout du compte on
en est arrivé là parce qu'on a favorisé
ces extrémistes pour favoriser nos
extrémistes à nous et donc là la société
israélienne est une société démocratique
il va y avoir des questions réelles qui
vont se poser avec des enquêtes avec et
C pour l'instant pour l'instant on va
dire que la société israélienne est
favorable à la contre-attaque à la
contre-attaque mais jusqu'à quel point
est-ce que on peut imaginer que la
société se retourne au moment où il
risque d'y avoir des des pertes énormes
dans la bataille dans Gaza alors se
retourne je ne pense pas mais il va y
avoir des bruits qui vont dire bon ça
suffit il y a un moment faut qu'est-ce
que vous avez obtenu bon ça va on s'en
va ou bien faut y aller jusqu'au bout
parce que vous avez pas obtenu donc ça
va être une gestion là on va rentrer
dans l'action militaire ça va être une
gestion purement militaire ça va être de
dire ok jusqu'où on va et qu'est-ce
qu'on donne comme preuve que ce qu'on a
fait est une
réussite